lies in crime in the far northwest
valley people in sky canyon say as their
community continues to grow thieves are
taking advantage and they want to put a
stop to it jeremy j ford is live in the
newsroom tonight with more jeremy well
thanks sasha and the sky cane community
does continue to grow but with new
housing developments but the residents i
spoke to about porch pirates and recent
thefts tell me crime in the area is on
the rise
a lot of people they come out the case
the area they've
not just in our neighborhood but a lot
of packages have been stolen david
erickson has been a sky cane resident
for more than two years and says more
and more residents are having items
stolen there's been occasions where i've
chased people out
between the hours of one and five in the
morning when they commonly do their
case into the area and look for easy
targets
resident victor zamora says thieves are
stealing packages off porches and
construction material for new
developments a lot of people ain't home
during the day
construction sites i know are getting
hit by
people stealing either supplies or fuel
with new construction he says gates
sometimes remain open and anyone can go
in giving this advice to homeowners buy
a ring camera get
adt you know somebody that's
going to do security for you guys
now some communities in skycam do have
on-site security that patrol the area
but several residents suggest the best
way to prevent theft in the community is
to get to know your neighbors and if you
see something say something from the
newsroom jeremy j ford 8 news now